Tatort Deutschland präsentiert den
dunklen Januar jeden Tag ein neuer
Kriminalfall die Ermordung ramsis des
dritten der Kannibale von Rotenburg und
viele weitere Fälle hier kommt der
dunkle Januar ein tägliches Tatort
Deutschland Spezial mein Name ist scary
und ich wünsche euch eine spannende
Krimi Zeit
und mein Name ist Natalie Strauß hallo
und herzlich willkommen zu unserem
Tatort Deutschland Spezial ich bin
Radiomoderatorin und werde im täglichen
Geschäft oft mit schrecklichen
Verbrechen konfrontiert hier wollen wir
aber nicht auf den normalen Horror
schauen sondern uns Kriminalfälle
vornehmen die uns nicht mehr losgelassen
haben seit wir sie das erste Mal hatten
und am besten erzählt euch diese Stories
der Sprecher und Moderator und Mirko
Kasimir schön dass wir das hier wieder
zusammen machen dürfen hallo Natalie die
Freude ist ganz meinerseits schön dich
zu sehen du hast vollkommen recht es
gibt einfach die Geschichten die wir uns
immer wieder erzählen weil sie uns
einfach so faszinieren und weil sie
manchmal wie in diesem Fall auch Eingang
in die Kultur finden ja und da sind wir
quasi schon beim Thema Peter Jackson der
sagt euch allen ja was oder richtig
erkannt erst der Regisseur von Herr der
Ringe aber was viele glaube ich gar
nicht wussten dass einer seiner ersten
großen Erfolge auf einer true
crime-story beruht nein es geht hierbei
nicht um Zombie Komödie Braindead ja die
beruhte so weit ich weiß nicht wirklich
auf wahren Begebenheiten es geht um
Heaven die creatures der ist 1994
erschien ist tatsächlich auch Kate
Winslets erste Kinorolle sie spielte
darin ein Teenager namens Juliette Huhn
eine Mörderin und die wahre Geschichte
die Peter Jackson und seine Partnerin
Fran Walch zu diesem Film inspirierte
die hören wir jetzt Mirko es ist der 22
juni 1954 ein wunderschöner Wintertag in
Christchurch ich muss hier an dieser
Stelle mal ganz kurz unterbrechen
Christchurch liegt auf der Südinsel von
Neuseeland also auf der komplett anderen
Seite des Globus ist unser Sommer ist
deren Winter wenn Mirko also sagten
wunderschöner Wintertag dann redet er
nicht jetzt vom Skifahren oder so die
Durchschnittstemperatur im Juni liegt
dort bei etwa 11 Grad und bevor sich
jemand fragt nein der Strudel im
Spülbecken dreht sich nicht anders herum
als bei uns ja kleine Oma schon die
Simpsons
Tutorial Park liegt in den Hügeln im
Südwesten der Stadt Einwohner hat
Besucher lieben ihn und an einem Tag wie
heute hat man von dort oben einen
atemberaubenden Ausblick auf die Stadt
es gibt Wanderwege Spielplätze üppiges
Grün und riesige Rasenflächen und ein
kleines Café das an diesem Tag gut
besucht ist die Menschen genießen die
Sonne ihren Tee und ihren mit Fleisch
und Käse gefüllten Pie meine Idylle eine
Idylle die zum Albtraum wird Hilfe Mami
ist verletzt schreit eins der beiden
jugendlichen Mädchen die aus dem Waldweg
herausgerannt kommen sie ist voller Blut
die Gäste des Kaffees reagieren
schockiert denn die beiden Mädchen sind
selbst mit Blut befleckt viel Blut
eigenes Richie die Besitzerin des Cafés
erkennt die beiden wieder denn noch für
ein paar Minuten haben Sie hier mit
einer älteren Frau etwas gegessen dann
sind die drei in den Wald gegangen
soweit eigentlich nichts ungewöhnliches
die Mädchen sind verwirrt und panisch
Mami ist gestürzt sagt die 16-jährige
Pauline Parker bitte wir brauchen Hilfe
ihre Freundin Juliette John 15 Jahre alt
wimmert sie ist gestürzt da ist so viel
Blut
eigenes für die beiden in das Café und
versucht sie zu beruhigen während ihr
Mann Richard der verletzten Frau zu
Hilfe eilt doch was er etwa 130 Meter
weiter auf dem kleinen Waldweg findet
sieht ganz und gar nicht nach einem
Sturz aus
ganz im Gegenteil sogar die Frau die da
liegt die ist nicht verletzt ihr Kopf
ist zerschmettert und ich meine
buchstäblich zerschmettert es ist
überall blutverteilt dieser Anblick der
muss schockierend gewesen sein die Frau
ist tot und Nora Reaper die Mutter von
Pauline Parker wurde nur 45 Jahre alt
und schnell wird klar dass die beiden
jungen Frauen nicht die Wahrheit
erzählen sie sei gestürzt behaupten sie
und dann habe sie sich hin und her
gewälzt und aber immer weiter verletzt
eine absolut unglaubwürdige Geschichte
aber die Alternative ist noch viel
schwerer zu ertragen haben die Mädchen
etwa gelogen
aber wenn dann würde das ja bedeuten
dass sie etwas mit ihrem Tod zu tun
haben und das will sich zu diesem
Zeitpunkt niemand vorstellen die Mädchen
werden zu den News gebracht Juliette
Eltern sie nehmen ein Bad ihre
blutbefleckte Kleidung wird zu
Trockenreinigung gebracht pauline ist
still und in sich gekehrt während Juliet
unauffällig plappert über alles mögliche
nur nicht über das was im Park geschehen
ist und dann am Abend die beiden Mädchen
liegen im Bett steht die Polizei vor der
Tür
wir alle wissen die Story mit dem Sturz
ist weit entfernt von glaubwürdig die
Polizei hat den Ort des angeblichen
Sturzes untersucht und hat unter einem
nahegelegenen Baum eine bluttrinkende
Socke gefunden in der ein Ziegelstein
steckt
honora Reaper ist erschlagen worden und
die Hauptverdächtigen sind in diesem
Fall ganz klar ihre Tochter Pauline und
deren beste Freundin Juliet ich meine
dieser Fall ist so schon grausam genug
jemanden möglicherweise mit einem
Ziegelstein zu erschlagen aber dann
handelt es sich hierbei noch um die
eigene Tochter das macht es ehrlich
gesagt noch abartiger und genau das will
niemand glauben denn so etwas das darf
einfach nicht sein schon gar nicht hier
in diesem wunderbaren Land die Stadt
Kreis church taumelt schrieb damals
einen Kommentator Teenager Mädchen
laufen nicht herum und töten ihre Mütter
na aber Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel
aber damit wir jetzt wenigstens eine
Idee davon bekommen warum wieso weshalb
müssen wir noch ein Stück weiter zurück
in die Vergangenheit also Mirko
Julia jung und Pauline Parker kennen
sich zum Zeitpunkt der Tat seit
zweieinhalb Jahren sie besuchen beide
die Girls High School in Christchurch
und ihre Freundschaft ist ziemlich
ungewöhnlich Julians Familie kommt aus
England und ist ziemlich wohlhabend ihr
Vater ist nuklear Physiker und brachte
seine Familie nach Neuseeland als ihm
die Stelle als Direktor der Canterbury
University in Christchurch angeboten
wurde Pollin hingegen stammt aus der
Arbeiterklasse das Haus das ihre Familie
bewohnt dient auch als einfache Herberge
betrieben von ihrer Mutter ihr Vater
arbeitet in einem Fischgeschäft doch es
gibt auch viele Gemeinsamkeiten zwischen
den Mädchen beide haben seit der
Kindheit mit gesundheitlichen Problemen
zu kämpfen Pauline waren osteomelitis
erkrankt einer schmerzhaften Infektion
der Knochen und des Knochenmarks Juliet
hatte sich mit Tuberkulose infiziert und
war vor dem Umzug ins milde Neuseeland
mehrmals auf die Bahamas und nach
Südafrika geschickt worden um sich zu
kurieren
aber noch wichtiger ist dass die Mädchen
Bücher lieben sie sind äußerst
intelligent und verfügen über eine
lebhafte Fantasie die beiden beginnen
sich eine eigene Welt auszumalen und
Geschichten zu erfinden und irgendwann
wird das den Geschichten ein Spiel mit
der Wirklichkeit sie geben sich neue
Namen Pauline nannte sich Gina Juliette
Deborah und schließlich erfinden sie
sogar ihre eigene Religion in der
Theorie ist das ja okay aber wenn die
Grenzen anfangen zu verblassen dann
wird's echt schwierig also ich meine das
ist ja ganz normal dass man als Kind
oder Jugendlicher eine sehr ausgeprägte
Fantasie hat ich kenne das selber von
mir als ich ein Kind war wir hatten
Familie in den USA da hat meine
Schwester und ich vom Schlafengehen
immer gesagt so wenn wir jetzt schlafen
gehen und träumen dann besuchen wir
unsere Cousin und Cousins so und das
haben wir uns dann immer so ausgemalt
was wir dann machen und haben uns das am
nächsten Morgen erzählt ja ich glaube
das gehört auch einfach zum Kind sein
dazu aber
bis zu einer eigenen Religion zu treiben
das machen glaube ich nur die wenigsten
was auch noch wichtig ist die beiden
waren sicher nicht komplett der Realität
entrückt vielleicht war da auch ein
bisschen Ironie und Spaß im Spiel in
ihre Religion gab es zum Beispiel
Heilige und die benannten sie nach Stars
ihrer Zeit zum Beispiel nach Mario Lanza
in den 50er Jahren in ganz bekannter
Hollywood Schauspieler und Opernsänger
ja
ihre Familien die die Freundschaft trotz
der sozialen Unterschiede lange
toleriert haben beginnen sich aber
irgendwann Sorgen zu machen denn die
beiden scheinen immer mehr Zeit in ihrer
Fantasie Welt zu verbringen als sie
einen Doktor im Rat fragen vermutet
dieser dass die beiden eine sexuelle
Beziehung haben für die Familien ist das
der entscheidende Anstoß die beiden zu
trennen die beiden haben das übrigens
später immer bestritten ist aber auch
nicht ganz abwegig weil wir sprechen
über die 50er da gab es genau 0 Toleranz
für Homosexualität aber selbst wenn es
so gewesen wäre wenn die beiden ein das
Paar gewesen wären wäre es dann nicht
besonders grausam die beiden zu trennen
ich meine es waren andere Zeiten damals
war eine lesbische Beziehung strafbar
und es galt auch tatsächlich als
psychische Störung wenn das das mindset
der Eltern war dann ist es ja auch kein
Wunder dass sie da kein Risiko eingehen
und die beiden trennen wollten und die
Gelegenheit dazu ergibt sich schon recht
bald denn Juliets Eltern trennen sich
der Vater will nach Südafrika ziehen und
Juliet und ihren Bruder John F mitnehmen
Paulin beschließt daraufhin mitzugehen
nach Südafrika in die neue Heimat ihrer
besten Freundin und in ein neues Land
dass sie gemeinsam mit ihren Fantasien
ausfüllen können die beiden sind davon
überzeugt dass es nur ein Hindernis bei
der Verwirklichung dieser Idee
gibts Mutter der Anfang vom Ende ein
unfassbarer Plan nimmt Gestalt an
Pauline für Tagebuch das später von der
Polizei gefunden wird am 13 FE schreibt
sie warum konnte Mutter nicht sterben
Dutzende von Menschen sterben tausende
sterben jeden Tag warum also nicht auch
Mutter und Vater wow da klingt es noch
eher nach einem Wunsch als einem Plan
was schon schlimm genug ist am
28.4.1954 wird es dann aber noch
konkreter die Wut auf Mutter kochte in
mir hoch sie ist eines der größten
Hindernisse auf meinem Weg plötzlich
fiel mir ein Mittel ein um mich von
diesem Hindernis zu befreien ihrer
Freundin erzählt Pauline anfangs noch
nichts von diesen Mittel später weil sie
ihre Freunde dann ein und am 19 Juni
notiert sie ins Tagebuch wir haben alles
ausgearbeitet und sind beide von der
Idee begeistert natürlich sind wir ein
bisschen nervös aber die Vorfreude ist
groß der Tag steht kurz bevor es ist der
21 juni 1954 einen Tag vor der Tat
wir haben beschlossen einen Stein in
einem Strumpf zu benutzen statt eines
Sandsacks wir haben den Mord diskutiert
ich fühle mich aufgeregt als ob ich eine
Überraschungsparty vorbereiten würde die
Tagebuchseite des 22 juli versieht sie
am Morgen des Tages mit einer
Überschrift der Tag des Happy Ends das
ist so perfide ich meine den geplanten
Todestag der Mutter als Happy End zu
bezeichnen das ist das ist richtig krass
mindestens vier Monate lang hat Pauline
den Tod ihrer Mutter beschlossen und
geplant nicht weil die Mutter besonders
grausam gewesen wäre sondern weil sie
sie von ihrer besten Freundin fernhalten
wollte der Polizei gegenüber bleibt
Pauline bei der Geschichte des Sturzes
die Socke so erklärt sie habe sie
zufällig dabei gehabt und damit versucht
das Gesicht der Mutter abzuwischen daher
das Blut warum ein Stein in der Socke
steckte erklärt das weil ich nicht doch
schon bald gesteht Pauline den Mord ein
Auszug aus den Vernehmungsprotokoll
womit haben sie geschlagen mit einem
halben Ziegelstein in einem Strumpf ich
habe ihn dafür mitgenommen den
Ziegelstein hatte ich in meiner
Umhängetasche ich möchte betonen dass
Juliette nichts von meinen Absichten
wusste und mich sah wie ich meine Mutter
schlug ich habe die Gelegenheit
ergriffen meine Mutter zu schlagen
während Juliette Weg war ich möchte
immer noch nicht sagen warum ich meine
Mutter getötet habe haben Sie Julie
erzählt dass sie ihre Mutter getötet
haben sie wusste nichts davon soweit ich
weiß hat sie mir geglaubt obwohl sie
vielleicht geahnt hat was passiert ist
aber das bezweifle ich denn wir waren
beide so erschüttert dass es ihr
wahrscheinlich nicht in den Sinn kam
sobald ich anfing meine Mutter zu
schlagen bereut ich es konnte aber nicht
mehr aufhören
Paulines Tagebuch überführt auch Juliet
in einer späteren Vernehmung gesteht sie
ihre Beteiligung wir gingen zu einer
Stelle die weit unten auf einem der
Pferde lag auf dem Rückweg ging ich
voraus ich rechnete damit das misses
Parker angegriffen werden würde
ich hätte Geräusche hinter mir es war
eine laute wütende Unterhaltung ich ging
zurück ich sah wie Pollin misses Parka
mit dem Ziegelstein im Strumpf schlug
ich nahm den Strumpf und schlug sie auch
ich hatte schreckliche Angst ich dachte
dass einer von ihnen beiden sterben
müsste
misses Parka bewegte sich krampfhaft wie
hielten sie beide fest nach dem ersten
Schlag wusste ich dass es notwendig sein
würde sie zu töten ich war entsetzt und
hysterisch schon im August 1954 findet
der Prozess gegen Pauline Parker und
Julian statt ihre Verteidiger plädieren
auf Unzurechnungsfähigkeit unter anderem
sagt ein Psychiater aus die beiden
hätten an warenvorstellungen gelitten
aufgrund von Homosexualität der Prozess
ist eine Sensation in Neuseeland wegen
der Grausamkeit des muttermordes aber
wohl auch wegen solch unsinniger
Behauptungen das muss man sich mal
vorstellen dass das genutzt wird um den
Mädels zu helfen ich meine wie abgedro
ist das bitte aufgrund von
Homosexualität haben sie ihre Mutter
umgebracht das macht doch gar keinen
Sinn nach wenigen Tagen werden die
beiden Mädchen des maudes für schuldig
befunden aber aufgrund ihres
jugendlichen Alters entgehen sie der
Todesstrafe sie werden zu einer
unspezifischen Haftzeit nach Belieben
ihrer Majestät verurteilt und in
unterschiedlichen Haftanstalten
untergebracht fünf Jahre später werden
sie entlassen angeblich mit der Auflage
einander nie wieder zu sehen aber das
scheint ein Gerücht zu sein denn
offizielle Stellen weisen diese
Behauptung zurück
nach ihrer Entlassung verbrachte Pollin
Parker erst einige Zeit in Neuseeland
und zog dann nach England sie nahm den
Namen Hillary Nathan an und lebte fortan
zurückgezogen in einem kleinen Dorf in
der Grafschaft kennt Juliette ging auf
ihre Entlassung auch nach Großbritannien
arbeitete in diversen Jobs wurde
Mormonen und lebte eine Zeit lang in den
USA nachdem der Film heavy creatures
herauskam und ein so großer Erfolg wurde
ich habe ich ihr dennoch verrückt die
anderen sind verblödet deine Mutter ist
doch eine erbärmliche Frau oder nicht
ich weiß was wir mit Mutter tun müssen
machte sich ein Journalist auf die Suche
nach Juliette und hat eine ziemlich
sensationelle Entdeckung dabei gemacht
Juliet die schon immer so viel zu viel
wie manche sagen Fantasie gehabt hatte
war Schriftstellerin geworden jetzt
ratet mal welches Jahr ganz genau Krimis
Bücher über Morde die meist in
viktorianischen Zeitalter spielten
Julius hieß jetzt an Perry und ihre
Kriminalromane hatten sich bis dahin
mehr als 20 Millionen Mal verkauft Mirko
ich weiß ja nicht wie du das siehst na
aber ich finde es super krass dass diese
Mädels danach eigentlich ein ziemlich
normales und sogar sehr erfolgreiches
Leben weitergelegt haben ich meine wenn
man z.B den Wikipedia Eintrag zu Julien
also in Perry liest steht da zwar dass
sie wegen Mordes verurteilt wurde aber
es ließ sich ja belanglos fast schon
nebensächlich und ähm ja es fällt fast
gar nicht auf ansonsten wird sie im Netz
einfach nur als krasser Autorin gefeiert
wir haben natürlich gibt die recht für
mich ist dieser Fall genauso verstörend
wie für dich aber ich denke vielleicht
muss man berücksichtigen dass die beiden
zur Tatzeit noch Kinder bzw Teenager
waren aber auch das ist natürlich keine
Legitimation für das was passiert ist
für diese schreckliche Tat und ich finde
das was bei Wikipedia steht erlaubt uns
überhaupt keinen Einblick in ihre
Gedankenwelt und es ist
selbstverständlich absolut nicht
nachzuvollziehen weshalb jemand aufgrund
einer engen Freundschaft beschließt die
eigene Mutter zu töten aber für mich
scheint es so als hätten sich beide in
ihre eigenen Fantasiewelt immer mehr
voran so dass die Realität und die
Fiktion immer mehr miteinander
verschwommen
und haben sich dabei in ja eine
obsessive Abhängigkeit voneinander
geradezu reingesteigert ja und dass sie
dies taten weil sie angeblich lesbisch
sein und diese Liebe zu
Wahnvorstellungen geführt haben könnte
ist natürlich absoluter Blödsinn aber
ist auch ein Sinnbild für die damalige
Zeit in der gleichgeschlechtliche Liebe
noch als Krankheit galt aber so oder so
waren es zwei Mädchen die offensichtlich
keinen anderen Ausweg wussten als onora
Reaper zu töten um zusammen bleiben zu
dürfen glücklicherweise gibt es
heutzutage Kinder und Jugendpsychologen
die helfen könnten
Mädchen wie Juliet und Pauline die in
eine Fantasiewelt abtauchen und diese so
extrem mit in die Realität nehmen können
heute viel besser betreut werden und
sollten nicht das Gefühl bekommen dass
der Rest der Welt sich gegen sie
verschworen hätte
das war's für heute eine verstörende
Geschichte eine faszinierende Geschichte
großes Kino zumindest nachdem Peter
Jackson sie sich vorgenommen hatte
wir danken euch fürs zuhören und hoffen
dass ihr bei der nächsten Folge wieder
dabei seid bei Tatort Deutschland
Spezial euer Mirko und eure Natalie
den Fall Honorar Parker haben wir
nacherzählt mit Informationen des
neuseeländischen Portals nautulave sowie
digitalen Einträgen in der Bibliothek
von Christchurch
Redaktion Antonia Heier und Stefan
netzert Produktion Serverdienst